Rhianna brings the x-games to Fashion
Week plus Beyonce returns to her
hometown to help serve food while
Kristen Bell belted frozen Tunes for
hurricane ARMA victims bad did you guys
miss me as much as I missed you probably
not because I have attachment issues but
welcome back to the daily deni we've got
some feel-good stories for you guys
today
but first let's get into Rihanna because
RiRi just straight-up owned New York
Fashion Week and everyone is talking
about for a high-energy
venti by Puma fashion show we have Kanye
West as a no-show this year the
spectacle deservedly belonged to Rihanna
who literally brought the x-games to
Fashion Week if you look closely that is
a trio of bikers who revved up their
motorcycles performing flips over
mountains of millennial pink sand a list
models like Joan Smalls kaya Gerber
Adriana Lima rocked the collection and
of course saved the tricks for the
professionals but Rihanna herself did
climb on back on one of the bikes for
the show's closer riding out in true
RiRi style guys I can't get enough of
this show and with that Rihanna
single-handedly made New York Fashion
Week fun again alright meanwhile Beyonce
returned to her hometown of Houston over
the weekend which has been left
devastated by hurricane Harvey B and
five-year-old daughter Blue Ivy arrived
at her childhood Church of st. John's
she gave a big momma bear hug to friends
family and victims before taking the
stage with mom Tina now the stars are
joining forces from Texas to now Florida
where Kristen Bell provided a helpful
distraction to those displaced by
Hurricane Emma
Kristen is in Florida filming her new
movie like father and in what is sure to
be the sweetest video you've seen all
day Kristen belted frozen Tunes to 200
evacuees holed up at the meadow woods
middle school in Orlando Florida
[Music]
Kristen was clearly on a mission and her
charity was just the beginning because
her frozen co-star Josh God's parents
were stranded and saved by the Kristen
Bell when she found them a room at her
hotel josh tweeted Kristen Bell just
literally saved my parents my brothers
and entire family from hurricane Emma
you are an angel I adore you you know
who is another blunt actress I adore
Jennifer friggin Lawrence
Jayla is in the middle of an
international press blitz with her
director boyfriend Darren Aronofsky et's
Cameron Mathison got to chat with
Jennifer at the premiere of their film
mother where she couldn't help but gush
about her man but she also couldn't hold
back a burp watch closely
see you nice to see you I got to watch
the movie this morning it was incredibly
intense and powerful and
thought-provoking and all of the above
and I couldn't help but notice that your
it was just unbelievably intense journey
for you and I know you put your all and
I mean did you really tear your
diaphragm is that right I did yeah but
from emotions not from like nobody beat
me or sees the movie they'll understand
I had to go to a place nobody
sorry burped nobody should go working
with your partner Derek collaborated on
this what makes him so great he's I mean
his his point of view is his artistic
uniqueness he's just brilliant he's
incredibly instinctual as for what
Darren thinks makes j-law great he says
she is a once-in-a-generation talent and
he blames it on the Kentucky water
all right meanwhile it was a big weekend
for a slew of TV stars at the creative
arts Emmys James Corden won for
outstanding variety special for carpool
karaoke Dave Chappelle and Melissa
McCarthy scored Emmys for hosting SNL
and Rory Gilmore herself aka Alexis
Bledel
earned her first Emmy for her role in
The Handmaid's Tale and as our Courtney
tezo found out alexis was still so
overcome with emotions backstage after
the win
has to feel amazing right now I can kind
of see it hit the reaction already
through your body language how are you
feeling I'm surprised and really excited
and yeah a little emotional I don't know
it's all the feelings what does it mean
to win for the hamate ELLs though this
story in particular so much I mean I'm
so fortunate to be a part of such an
incredible company of actors and to get
to tell this story now it's just such an
honor people have had such strong
reactions to it at a husband at home and
I'm sure your family's so proud how are
you guys gonna celebrate this way I
don't know I don't know I can't I still
can't believe I won I think I'm still
sort of in that headspace well you
better believe it Alexis I'm so excited
that she won last night which means
we'll also get to see her this Sunday
when the Primetime Emmy Awards are
handed out I'll be there to bring all
the fun moments on the red carpet and
those air this Sunday on CBS that's it
for today guys rest up buttercups
because tomorrow we'll have a brand new
daily journey for you until then like
and share this video and thank you as
always guys for watching I'll see you
bye